oh you watch rap battles oh yeah stop
dude
oh really we're just talking about just
talking about them what do you do
i love them it's so funny have you ever
seen the one where the guy
like his i think his cousin or his
sister died of cancer the guy gets in of
picture
starts roasting the and everyone's like
too far dude like even the crowd was
like damn
oh [ __ ] no but did you hear bars though
we needed to know that uh
it wasn't great it was just like it was
just like making people
make people feel uncomfortable i love
rap battles i love wrestling i watch
i do i can sit there and literally watch
them just leave i love i love how
auto play i love how like when you know
you losing they always just drink some
water
why you ain't that thirsty have you ever
seen them when they get so heated the
dude is just getting lit up [ __ ] just
shocks the dude oh yeah matthew versus
dose he was like yo
i'm style you don't like how i'm styling
on you you don't like how i'm shining on
you he was like bro get out my face
like man shut up man i ain't getting out
your face you know like uh and just
socked them and
the whole fight knocked him out now they
just they erupted look look
uh here it is like mouth hopper versus
uh you wouldn't be
appalachian you're just getting lit up
and you don't have
you want matt hoffa oh yeah this dna
versus chest
i would never start off a fight by
touching my face to another man's face
[Applause]
oh damn yeah that's a brawl
oh they about to fight tried to blend in
with the crowd while i [ __ ] my [ __ ]
a real talent man yeah be missed look at
that look at this
keep on
the cornrows
you can do whatever you want but that oh
this map hop again he
look watch out he's gonna sleep him he's
going to sleep
something get up out of here damn damn
that guy had like two or three fights
and you're i was like why you keep
fighting them back you're right i did
that with comedy like you're not
laughing at my job some of those
roasts right some of those no they they
keep it pretty good
yeah i'm sure there's been fights though
i don't think there's ever been a fight
in a row oh you're crazy
look at a rock any roast fights no i
guarantee there's been
bruh no one wants to i forget what it
was
there was that roast and uh and uh
who was in it and they went super low
blow about
getting a divorce like he was just newly
divorced he started talking about it
or ralphie may ralphie may was in it and
they started roasting him getting
divorced
his weight the way he looks oh really
but that's all
the anniversary of his death was the
other day october 6th rest in peace
and peace rapping yeah i didn't see any
fights but you want to see the savage
see there's no there's no
fights either there's been a fight in
rose battle no
no no it's different in louisiana
is different than rap battle roast i'm
telling you yeah
yeah fights do you ever see that uh i
figured it's a black comedian he was on
stage
and this dude and his girl they kept
talking
and he's like you're gonna shut up now
and the guy kept talking he's like dog
i'm telling you man
so he started lighting up his girl and
the dude goes say something about my
wife again and he roasts him the dude
went up there
and the dude had two big black security
guards on each side
and the dude goes get up there and
knocks him right out knocks the comedian
out
no knocks the the heckler who's trying
to get to the stage really and he's like
i told y'all and he keeps doing the show
oh he's like i told you don't come up
here are you serious
you see the one where the dude uh hits
the heckler with the guitar
yeah i saw that one oh no that's like
really cool that was a hard one it was
like
it was right here here's the one i'm
talking about are you of course it'll be
on world story
of course
i don't know where he's performing at a
damn bar oh
oh
that was his bit he kept having the
music play and the girl kept
then he'd roast the wife then hit the
music roast the wife with the music and
he was like y'all
you didn't quit talking about my wife
he's hanging dude [ __ ] and kept going at
her
and that's when he got on stage but
people got and they got knocked out
people get needed not getting their
feelings at a comedy show come on man we
had
a chill it's jokes yeah is that do you
need cash
no i thought it was an electric guitar
though no he hit someone
you got a 12-string 12-string guitar
right there look at a little
you know oh really watch
i can't see it bro people start booming
right
yeah people got mad at him they're like
yo you didn't need to do that
i'm sorry i watch a lot of wwf that
should have that guitar should have
what do you think folks he goes what do
you think folks and they go
no man shows yo yeah show's over homie
look at
you he was like he came at me like you
didn't need to do all that he tried to
explain himself afterwards comedian
come here
oh wait hold on it's never good or just
says comedian punched on things
there was one comedian it was like two
years ago three years ago
where he was getting beat with like the
microphone stand security oh i've seen
that
yeah you seen that yeah i think it was
in like a hole here you go
oh maybe that would shut you up
oh that's a girl that's a that's a girl
that's
like you're gonna hurt me it is a girl
huh
i love how she didn't hurt him she was
like okay where do we go from here now a
yelp review
oh oh two of them
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] is this i can't believe it
i got two women on stage trying to beat
me
no you just shut off during my show get
off the stage it's just
another one nothing even happened oh man
man that was weird i love how they got
those two women to show up like hold on
bro
it's embarrassing can mean slam second
on the head of the guitar yeah that's
the same one
dude i've never seen somebody light up a
heckler like uh
dane cook man dan cook one of the best
uh you know who i've seen light up one
really good you saw marc maron
like this uh gary owen oh really yeah
it's actually online he makes one of his
dude named dusty or something like that
he's just go
goes off on this dude because the guy
went shut up yeah he was like talking
[ __ ] and gary
i think he was just doing like a uh
guest spot or something
yeah that uh this one yeah he lights
this dude up
i love gary oh gary's great gary dressed
like
he don't hate mine
[Music]
not this [ __ ] i'm frustrated
people have to be known
[Applause]
you know the disc is so good when you
people don't even know what the person
looks like but
he says something you just you already
get it i've seen rogan light a dude up
but it is just mean
yeah you're like oh [ __ ] like we were
doing uh where was that oh i was at the
wilbur in boston
and he did like i don't like 15 minutes
up top then brought me out
he was like and then after we'll both
come out we'll do we'll just have like
have people do questions
yeah but there's one dude in the front
the cap [ __ ] yelling
and roman was fine like dude what the
[ __ ] is your deal and he was like um
he said he said he was like a veteran
somebody had a scarf on and ron's like
ain't no [ __ ] veteran wearing that
gay ass scarf
and dude starts lighting them up and
even i was like there's a picture of me
like this
oh really yeah it was that bad looking
like this i'm like this
y'all's damned why would you actually
look out the best to ever do it was
patrice o'neill talk that talk
oh yeah he go after you emotionally
remember uh
uh no uh total total total but it
totally wasn't heckling
it was it was uh some uh some he was
going after some black girl
you know and she was like eating her
chicken nuggets he was going off on her
and she said something to her mm-hmm he
ate her up and he ate up some other girl
on uh some guys are great they're like
deleted scenes on the special yeah i
know i saw that elephant in the room
watch that
another elephant in the room great great
class one of the best classics
another one you don't want to [ __ ] with
if you go to the show's andrew schultz
oh yeah he goes in oh too oh yeah he had
an entire special crowd work
where he came out and just did crowd
work you do crowd work
yeah you should watch that okay that
should be your homework okay tell your
queen that's what you're watching there
you go schultz is a monster he's in the
right now he's the best in the game he
has an entire special just off crowd
work
this has like three million views that's
great damn
he's a [ __ ] monster you don't do much
crowd work at all
uh unless it's like out like if it
unless it's super unique when i come out
it's like the elephant the room
or if like they're like i mean you would
have to be rabbit bee rabbit
oh yeah the guy boy i got pulled up in a
lambo
that's my friend sucks is he he's a big
fan he's been like multiple
shows but he went he wouldn't pipe down
he was running around he was drunk
yeah so it's like dude you're
interrupting the crowd and you're gonna
dress like that
well now i gotta do something yeah yeah
yeah yeah you called him but by the way
great guy that's your boy dude you just
bought it you started
i know my queen makes six figures i
don't need them anymore oh yeah you
don't need them
i don't need him your queen your queen
could rattle them she can really
but when i get off stage at the lap
factory right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son